あの えっと これからあのカマッターナサンガーヴィバーガという瞑想の説明なんです
で 今までの説明は一応この瞑想のためにあったアビダンマの説明で
で  ページの番目サマタカマッターナナイ
瞑想というのはサマタとヴィパッサナーと二つに分けてます
で 大体瞑想はサマタ ヴィパッサナーと二つに分けてます
で 仏教ではね 仏教で言ったっても
このパーリ仏教ではそう一応つめられます
で サマタっていうのは心のこの混乱状態
落ち着いてくるというですことをですね
精神的に安定する状態作ること
ですね サマタっていうのはこのPacificationという英語の言葉を使ってますから
この 心の落ち着き 心の混乱状態なくすこと
乱れている状態なくすこと
作るのがサマタなんですね
で 私の定義にはあまりあの認めない方々は
テキストやらいろんなところにそれなりの定義ありますから
そこに勉強なさってください
で ヴィパッサナーっていうのは
あの 見るという意味で
あの智慧の実践みたいな方ですね
ですから 明確に見るという明確に観察する方法
サマタでは心は落ち着いてくる
だからどんな馬鹿にも心落ち着いていることができます
で ヴィパッサナーっていうのはすごく鋭く智慧が働いていると
で それはまあそれほどバカな人にできるわけじゃないんだけど
かなり観察能力は必要なんですね
ですから サマタはもう誰にでもできるんです
アホであればあるほどやりやすいんです
サマタ瞑想は ヴィパッサナー瞑想はもう万人に人ぐらいでもできる人っていうのはいないんです
で そこを逆転してみんなヴィパッサナーやってサマタやる人は少ないんですけどね
でも本当にやってるかないかっていうことはもうすぐわかるんです
本当に智慧が発達しているかないかということはね
はっきりしていることですから
まあ一応あの悪く言えばそんなことで
サマタ瞑想っていうのはまあやりやすいですよ
落ち着くっていうことは
でもみんなにやりやすいわけでもないんです
精神的に生まれつきもうダメな人はダメなんです
で 生まれた時からもう感情的で病的でもうすぐ怒るは怒り出すはもう欲出しちゃうわ
であまりにも欲出して
もうすごいみんなに迷惑をかけるとかね
例えばもう何千何億円も借金して商売始めたりとかね
その欲でそういうことをやって
また全部パーになって
もう破産したりとかね
そういう風なこの感情激しい人にはサマタ瞑想もできません
でもそういう人は途中でよく出家するんですけど
日本では で 出家してテレビでも取材してくれるんです
いろんなところで頑張って修行しているんだと
で やっぱり科学的に見るとね
まあダメなやつはダメということで
社会で失敗したんだから
修行の世界で成功するんだというのはなんか理屈が合わないんです
で 生まれつきそういう性格ができてない人々はこの感情の問題だから
特にこの商売やるのはもう感情は高い人々なんです
すごい商売の世界で成功している人を見ると
頭が全く悪くて感情だけはすごく働いてるんですね
だからああなりたい こうなりたい
これぐらい儲かりたいというぐらいで
あのもうモネの絵を買ったとかね
あんな見かけ面白いこれを買って何の意味もないんだけど
ただそれですごく威張っちゃうとかね
五百万円の壺を買ったとかね
で 花一本も立てませんだけど
で そういう風な この別に美学的な能力とかそれもないしね
ですから そういう人々っていうのは
この 感情型で 世界で一番有名な美術さんにしたってもね
知識型じゃないんです
すごい感情型なんです
頭が悪いです 本当は 彼がプログラム作ってるわけじゃないんだから
ですから 世界一今支配者になってますけどね
そういう人々には瞑想
サマタ瞑想でも無理だろうと思います
ですから このサマタっていうのは
そういう心を落ち着いてくる状況で
あの いくらか基本的には人ができているということは必要なんです
で ヴィパッサナーっていうのはもっと難しくて
まあ落ち着いて大人しくいるっていうことは誰にでもできますけど
それゆえこの物事を理解して行動的になるっていうことはもっと難しいんですね
そういうわけで この これは瞑想の科学的な見方ですからね
私にとってはどうしようもないことで
僕はありのまま説明します
認めないんだったら それはご自由にご都合
授業だからね もう ありのまま
この経典にあるようなことを
経典では一応抑えて言ってますけどね
私は抑えません そのまま言います
で ですから 人間のありようから見れば
まあ瞑想できる人々というのは少ないんです
その少ない人々の中でも
ヴィパッサナーできる人はもっとすごく少ないんです
で それ上で言うならば
例えばこの本物の科学者とかね
ものすごい大変なこと
もう時代の驚きほどのものを発見したりして
そういう科学者っていうのは少ないんですね
科学を知っている人はいくらでもいるんですね
科学の博士とか何とかという人々はいくらでもいる
でも科学者は少ない 医者っていうのはもうどこでもいるんですけど
でもすごいこのノーベル賞をもらうぐらいのものすごい大変な奇跡的な能力を発揮して
いろんなことをやってくれる医者っていうのは少ないんですね
稼がれたほど少ないんです
そういうふうなもので
瞑想できる人々の中でも
ヴィパッサナーっていうのはちゃんとできるのは少ないんです
とにかく瞑想はそれで二種類に分けて
このなぜ二種類に分けたかというと
この 瞑想のやり方 見方なんですね
どんなふうにやればよろしいかと
だから主観的で 感情を抑えることを計算しながら瞑想するのはサマタ瞑想で
客観的で理解 を開発しながら瞑想するのはヴィパッサナー瞑想
だから瞑想の基本的なやり方も違うんです
サマタ瞑想は主観的に自分の心の状態
感情を抑えていくことを考えてやる瞑想で
主観客観的で理解智慧を発達する
何がわかるかと 何が発見できるものあるかという感じで
自分ということを置いておいて
客観的に知恵というものを目指して心を育てる方法はヴィパッサナーなんですね
同じ心の育ち方なんですけど
育ち方二つなんですね
で 昔風の家だったら 昔風の家族で男一人と女一人がいるんだったら
子供が女の子を家の中でいい
いい 何て言いますか いいお嫁さんになるように教育させる
ですから 家の中を綺麗にして
花を立てたり 料理を作ったり
洗濯をしたりとかね お母さんをお手伝ったりとか
それからおしゃれしたりとかね
そういうふうに女の子が育てると
それで男の子がそうじゃなくて
外へ出ていろんなことをやったり
喧嘩したり あだこだとか
外に出すような感じで母親が育てるというケース考えちゃうと
今は違いますけど これ昔風の家庭を想定して言うならば
そうすると女の子がサマタ的な成長で
男の子がヴィパッサナー的な成長なんですね
いわゆる主観的な心の
いわゆる母親が子供を育てているんです
ただそれだけのことなんですけど
一人が主観的に育てる
もう一人が客観的に育てるというふうな場合は
それもそういうふうな差なんですね
サマタヴィパッサナーっていうのは
でもそれはもう全くもう
でもどこを見せてるんですか？と
男の子には世界を見せてるんですね
世界の中で戦って競争して
何か生きて生き続けなくちゃいけない
女の子に世界を見せてるんじゃないんです
世界を見るなと じろじろとみんなと笑って話すなと
女の子でしょうと あなたは
ちゃんとおとなしくしなさいと母親が育てると
でも母親は二人とも育ててるんですけど
でも見せてる世界は違うんです
そういうふうにこのもう昔の時代ではね
で そうやって子供を育てたということを想定して考えちゃうと
もしそうであったならば
男の子は男の子はなんとなくヴィパッサナー的な育ち方で
女の子はサマタ的な育ち方ということになっちゃうんです
だから主観的か客観的に修行する
修行は主観的にするか
客観的にするかっていうことなんです
そこでサマタ瞑想については
このあんまりこの具体的に
私には説明するのは難しいんですけど
まあいろいろ 他の人にも聞いて勉強していただきたいんです
これどこからやればいいかな？がっかりわからない
一応瞑想に使う言葉はまず出てきます
一番最初にサマタ瞑想
で サマタ瞑想っていうのは落ち着くための瞑想
で 結果としてはかなり一番結果早いのはサマタ瞑想なんですね
すぐ人が良くなるんです
例えば 怒ってすごいもう感情的でコントロールできない人がいるならば
サマタ瞑想をやればすぐ瞬時に心が落ち着くんです
ですから 早くも人の心を強調して調教して落ち着いてもらうためには
サマタ瞑想の方がすごくいいんです
で 早いんです そこでサマタ瞑想をどのようにやればいいかというと
これはどんな方法でもいいんです
自分のあの激しい感情を抑えておくためには
あの何 どんな方法でもいいんです
だから心の激しい感情が抑えてきましたというならば
その方法はサマタ的なんです
ですから 音楽聴くとかね
踊るとか呪文唱えるとか
いろんな服装で決まるとかね
で 宗教儀式 儀礼ではまあ着る服にしても大変なこの仕来りあるんです
で 例えばこういう宗教的な衣とか何とか着たりして
それでいろいろもうシルクでできた糸ですか
この紐とかいろいろありますね
それの結び方でも これはこういうふうに結ぶんだと
こういうふうに結んではいけませんと
いろいろ決まりがあるんです
そこで色を模様とかね
で あの私よりは皆様方知っていると思いますけどね
まあまあ カトリック教の儀式をお祀りすれば
服装についてはかなり厳しいしきたりがあります
で 日本の宗教を見ても
例えば真言密教とかね
で そういう儀式に従っていろんな服装が決まってるんです
で もっと日本で人気あるチベット仏教にしたら
それぞれの宗教法事によって着るものは変わっちゃうんですね
いろいろ仮面かぶったりとかね
まあやってるんです チベットチベット教では
で そうやってある 何て言いますか
これは私はこの昔勉強してた時はまあ単なるReligious experienceという言葉を使ってたんだけど
なんとなく宗教的なこの経験みたいなものをこの得ようとするんですね
だから宗教 何か宗教儀式やろうとして
何かすっごい金銀ギラギンの服を着て
その上ですごいデッカい冠をかぶって
で それから顔にも何か仮面をかぶって
また手にいろんなアクセサリーやら手で持ついろんな道具やら履物やら
そんなものいっぱい着たところで
その人の心はそれなりに気持ちが変わるんですね
そこでそれを見ている人々も
ものすごい迫力があって圧倒されるというか
落ち着いてくることがあるんですね
そうやって宗教の世界では
人々を落ち着くために
何か清々しい気持ちというか
このいわゆるこのスピリチュアリティという精神精神性を作るために
心の中で精神的な感覚を作るためにいろんな方法をやっているのです
で 日本ではもうよく見られますし
外国に行かなくても わざわざティベットまで行かなくても見られるし
特に神道よりも仏教の儀式では
そういう気持ちをよく落ち着いている清々しい気持ちを作ろうとちゃんとやっているんです
神道の祭りというのが
いくつかありますけどね
例えばこの能ですか あれは神道の祭りの一部なんですね
で その神様のために何か踊ってあげたりはすると
その場合はすごい品格のいい
すごい美しい感じで徹夜して踊りをしてあげるという場合は
いくらかなんとなく気持ちよくなるという
で 日本仏教になると もうこれはもうかなりどんな儀式見たっても派手な仏教儀式見たっても
すごく落ち着いている
全く派手ではない仏教儀式見たっても
心を落ち着いてくれるようないろんな方法はあるんです
例えば木魚というものがありますね
何か木で作った音を立てる打楽器
打楽器ですか で そういう音でも聞くと聞いて
あの なんとかあの なんて言いますか
ワンシラブルワンシラブルで音程を上げているんだから
音楽で見ても ノートちゃんと一つ一つ一つ一つとね
4分の1ですか  で  4分の1でちゃんとできているんだから
まあ聞いてると落ち着いてきて
やがて寝ると で それに唱えて
また繋げて 例えば木魚がね
トントントントントントン
ちゃーんとやっちゃうでしょうね
そういうリズミカルな音を作って
で 聞いてる側とやってる側がなんかすごくありがたいことをしているんだと
すごくこの精神的に優れていることをしているんだという気持ちにはなる
その気持ちになると 悪いことはしてはいけませんと
怒ったり喧嘩したり 嫉妬したりしてはいけませんという気持ちが生まれてくるんです
それはカトリック教にしたって同じことなんです
だから 私たちはそういうのはいくらかの学問的に分析してみるんですね
仏教では 学問的に分析してみると
それは全部サマタのやり方といわれる METHOD OF PACIFICATION OF MIND ということなんですね
心はどのように PACIFICATION PEACEFUL ですか
平和な安定した心心をどのように作ればいいかというカテゴリーに入るんだと
乱暴な心を落ち着いて大人しい心にする
嫉妬したり 怒ったり 他の人と喧嘩したり
人のものを奪ったり ふしだらな生き方したりするしたがる心を落ち着いて大人しく生活できるようにする方法なんですね
サマタという方法 ですから
サマタの世界にかなりのものは入るんです
呪文も一つなんですね
呪文というのは意味が入ってない
何の意味もない ただ無意味な単語を言葉を選ぶ
ギャーギャーギャーギャーギャーギャーギャーなんとかとかね
ボディソワーガとかね
それはもうそんな発音に見ても何の意味もないんです
サンスクリット語で見てもガテーガテーパーラガテーパーラサンガテーボディスワハ
何の意味もないんです
だから言語学的に物事を考えるとアホですかと
あなたはと聞くぐらいのむちゃくちゃな言葉なんです
でもすっごい意味があるんだという
でも科学的じゃないんだから
人の能力次第 解釈できるんです
例えばアーカー もう例えば人という言葉がありますね
それはもう意味がある言葉だから解釈できません
人 まあ人は人で それで終わります
でもガテーガテーギャテーギャテーギャテーギャテーって言ったら意味がわかりません
だからいくらでも解釈できるんです
そこで能力次第に解釈できる
そこでそういう風に意味がない音だけ作る文化があります
それは呪文文化なんです
それもすぐ最近現れたものではなくて
人類の文明と一緒に これ紀元前3000年の4000年のところじゃないんです
もっと古いんです で もうそうやってこの音の文化があって
まあ人々というのは言葉を喋るようになった時
生まれたものだと思いますよ
で 言葉を始めた時は 何か自分の気持ちを相手に伝えるんですね
そこで何か言葉が出来上がっちゃうんですね
でも人には例えば気持ちはいっぱいあるんです
例えば言葉がない時代で
鹿が飛んでくるんだと
ここで狩りをやっているとお父さんが待っていて
息子がそこら辺にいるんですね
そこで息子さんに言わなくちゃ
鹿が来るんだから あんたこちらでちゃんといて逃げないように追い出せと
そうするとお父さんの方に逃げるんだから
ここで何か石でも何とかで殴って捕らわれました
捕まれますからね で それでお父さんがどう言えばいいんですかね
言葉がないんだから 何か喉から何か言葉を作らなくちゃいけないでしょうに
あーとかなんとかとか
それでその同じ言葉をしちゃうんだけど
今度来たのは鹿ではなくて
マンモスでした あるいは
もっと大きなサイとか
あるいは水牛でもいいんです
これ水牛は石で倒れる
倒れるわけにはいきませんし
子供が前に行っちゃったら子供を殺す可能性もあるし
それでお父さんがどうやって表現すればいいんですか？危ないよ
気をつけろ 逃げろと で
もう遠い時代ではお父さんが同じ言葉をするんです
それで子供は自分で助からない
なかったならば すぐ 殺される可能性もあったあるんですね
それは私は想定して言うことだけなんですけど
そこで私は言いたいのは
言葉が出てきた時代では
でも言いたいこといっぱいあるんだけど
言葉がないんです その問題は今も私たちにあるんです
言いたいこと 伝えたいこといっぱいあるんだけど
適切な単語はないと これほど言語自体が発達しているのにもないんです
だから文学っていうのは成り立つんです
上手な人々がこの我々知ってる単語は綺麗にあやすって作品書くと
だから私たちびっくりするんです
なぜならば 小説やら読むと全部自分知ってる言葉なんです
なんだこれと じゃあ知ってるんだったらあなたも書いてみなさいと言ったら書けませんね
だから文学作品というものは出来上がっちゃうでしょう
ですから その人々は特別タレントを持ってるんですね
みんな知ってる単語で
言葉で なかなか普通の人に表現できないことを感情を表現してしまう
それを文学と呼んでですね
そこでこの呪文の始まりってますけどね
言葉にはそれなりに力があるんですね
我々の感情を引き起こす力が
ですから この言葉に意味があったら引き起こす感情は決まってるんです
言葉に意味があると で
この勉強が終わったらおでんうどん食べましょうと言ったら感情は起こすでしょ
みんなに同じ感情なんです
一応一応同じなんで うどん嫌いな人は別として
一般的には あるいはうどんではなく
うどん食べますと言ったら
起こす感情はまあ大体は決まっている
ですから それ言葉に意味があるんだからなんです
勉強終わったからと言ったところで
終わってからと言ったら
ちゃんと勉強って何ですかと決まってあって
終わると言った途端 何時に終わるかとも
私のことだからあまりはっきりしませんかもしれませんだけど
一応何時に終わるかということがあって
そうやって意味がしっかりすると引き起こす感情は決まってるんです
もし意味がしっかりしていないと
どんな感情を引き起こすかわからないんですね
呪文というのはそういう世界で働くんです
ですから この怒りを引き起こす
尊い気持ち 引き起こす脅威
恐怖感 で これ宗教的な恐怖
あれはなんていうのは何て言いますか
この恐れ 恐れの気持ち
それ怖いという気持ちよりはちょっと違いますね
怯える気持ちとは違いますからね
神を恐れるというフィアオブゴッドということ
ですから その恐れを引き起こす
怒りを引き起こす 欲を引き起こすとか
いろんなものにこの呪文あるんです
ですから 呪文自体もかなり歴史古い文化の一つなんです
ですから 祟りがあるし
ブラックマジックもあるし
ホワイトマジックですか
そういういい方に祝福する呪文もあるし
あの農作 農業やってますからね
豊作のための呪文もあるし
雨が降るための呪文もあって
降水を止まってくれる
来てもらうためにも呪文があるんです
そこで美しくなるためにも呪文があって
人の美根を壊す 醜くする呪文もあります
人を健康にする 病気な人を健康にする呪文があって
健康な人を病気にしてすぐ瞬時に殺すとという呪文もあります
真面目に勉強してください
あることは確かにあるんです
いろんな呪文 で 真面目にやる人はいるんです
真剣真面目にこういう力があるんですよとかね
で そういうのはあの 人はいくら認めたっても
お釈迦様の仏教ではまるっきり認めない
それはなぜ認めないかというわけ
今私が説明しているだけなんです
言葉には意味がありますと
意味があると引き起こす感情は決まっている
言葉に意味がない場合は引き起こす感情は決まってないんです
それで引き起こしたい感情をグルー化して
それに無意味な言葉を入れちゃえば呪文の文化なんです
ですから 仏教的な知識がある人だったら
三千年 四千年から出来上がった呪文文化は一日で作られます
今コンピューターがありますから
一日でずっと片っ端から呪文文句を打って
それをカテゴリにして
商売繁盛の呪文これこれやと
安産の呪文これこれやと
で あるんです はっきりと
例えば子供がお腹にいて安産できないように
子供は この何て言いますか
この逆 逆子になって 母親も子供も一緒に死ぬための呪文とか
ものすごい苦痛 苦しみを得て
そこで子供がお腹の中で産む前に死ぬための呪文とかあります
そこで体に悪霊ついたら悪霊追い払う呪文もありまして
健康な人に悪霊のように乗り悪霊が乗乗するような呪文もあります
欲しい人は後で言ってください
項目とどんな呪文かと
すぐ探してあげます 自分で勉強したい方々は
このヴェーダ聖典の四番目のヴェーダ聖典を読んでみてください
アタルバンヨガヴェーダと読むんです
読むだけたり真面目にやってほしいんです
で それでこの なかなかね
人間がそういうのは信頼するということは消えませんだけどね
だから仏教という世界にも入り込んじゃったんですね
だからティベット仏教っていうのは呪文仏教で
で 矛盾だらけで すべては空やと言いながら一所懸命呪文をやっている
修行しなくちゃいけないと言いながら
解脱ことを正しいと言いながら輪廻転生ばっかり考えているとかね
で そこはまあ日本の仏教にもありましてね
いろいろ それで仏教になったところで
煩悩をなくす呪文と解脱できる呪文とかね
瞑想うまくいく呪文とかあります
で  [ silence ]
一つ二つ試しに教えようかなとは
まあ今はこの呪文の話になったんだから
用意してないんだけど
瞑想するとき使う呪文とかあります
で 座布団の下に呪文書いて
その上に座布団を入れて
それで座って瞑想するんです
そうすると瞑想がうまくいくんです
だからこの仏教の世界から見れば
座ったら寝るというのはもうかなり悪霊にやられているんですね
悪霊そのものなんです
だから波動が悪くて 他の修行者にとってもすっごい嫌な気持ちになる
それぐらいこの悪い霊の力があまりにもありすぎて
それでもそれなりの呪文を書いてあげて
体にもいろいろお守りをつけてあげて
除霊して 別な場所に入れておいて瞑想してもらうんです
で そういうテキストがスリランカにもありましたけどね
それはこのスリランカ人はもう一応それ信じませんだから大変損しました
この本というのは葉っぱで書くんだから
書き写さなくちゃいけないんですね
どうせ使わないし 信じてもないんだから書き写さなかったんです
そこでやっと一つの本を見つけて
どこかにあって たった一つだけ
だから学問的に研究もできないんです
それ一応書き写したんだよ
現代の紙に書き写すために
一枚開けたら その一枚がボロボロボロボロになって壊れる
何か間違ったかと書き写す
読み方違うんではなかった
その研究もできなかった
そこで古い葉っぱで書いたテキストを普通の紙に書き写したところであれはゴミ粉々というテキストも一つあります
その中にもいくらかの呪文とかね
ありましたね これから子供の熱とかね
いろいろ病気とか治す呪文がありましてね
それはいくらか覚えていますけど
ジャーロジャーロ マハジャーロ
ジャーランマハジャーリとか
回唱えたら冷たい水でも沸騰してくれるぐらい力ある呪文もあります
でも覚えてます 回唱えたら危ないんですが
もし体の中の結石でも熱くなったらどうしますか？大変なことになります
私はやったことはありますけどね
でもやっぱりやかん火の上にかけた方が早いんです
だから効率はもう最低というか
ほとんどゼロですけどね
まあそうやってこの呪文の話は今日の勉強に関係ないんだけど
そういう呪文文化にしたっても
我々の感情 いろんな感情を引き起こす
その中でも感情を抑えるという働きもあります
感情を引き起こすだけではなくて
抑えると そうやってこのオンとかオンマニパドメフンとかナンマクサンマンダラとかなんとかというとかね
そういう呪文は本当は感情を引き起こすではなくて抑えるために作った呪文なんです
そういう呪文は今日本では悪霊払いに使ってるんですけど
これ逆なんです チベット人にとっては徳を積む呪文などマニパドメフンというのは
あれの日本バージョンは何でしたっけ？覚えていない
真言知ってる方々は知ってるかもしれませんだけど
現代仏教と真言密教と関係ある方々いるならばその知っているだろうと思いますけど
観音様の呪文 でお地蔵様の呪文なら弘法大師を拝む呪文が何でしたっけ？それはみんな覚えてるでしょ
高野山に行ったら誰も言わなく
誰でも言わなくちゃいけないでしょ
あの呪文は まあとにかくこの仏教で作った呪文というのは
感情を抑えてくるだろうと思って作ったものなんです